[Music]
in the events of our times i'll be
putting my questions to tonight's
special guests
[Music]
good evening two innocent british people
for year after year they languished
locked up mistreated in one of the
world's most notorious prisons but their
spirit was unbroken and now at last
they're free last week nazanin zagari
ratcliffe and anushay ashori seized as
prisoners in iran returned home
it was the site their families longed
floor but after the euphoria of release
come the questions
why were they taken why for so long why
did it take five foreign secretaries
before they were freed tonight in his
only tv interview i talked to anusha
ashori
now back at home with his family this
[ __ ] civil engineer tells me of the
place he called the valley of hell
also tonight with faster pandemic than a
major war it looks like economic
turbulence is here to stay if you've
noticed your household bills going up
there's some bad news it's going to get
worse
so what a time to be chancellor of the
exchequer not long ago rishi sonak
opened up the public pass to furlough
millions during the cloverd crisis
but now he says he can't insulate us
from the coming storm i'll ask him why
not and whether he really feels affinity
with those who suffer the most
five years ago nazanin zagari ratcliffe
and anushay ashori were ordinary members
of the public british people of iranian
background they were plot from obscurity
by a terrible injustice arrested in
tehran and imprisoned by the iranian
government in the notorious evan prison
last week after years of campaigning by
their families they finally returned
home the cause of their release a deal
involving the uk paying iran a
historical debt of 400 million pounds
still another man is in a similar
predicament called morad tabes who
remains in jail i went to see anushay
ashori at his home in the suburbs of
south london admits his joy of coming
home i found a man tormented by
separation from those he left behind and
full of questions for those he feels let
him and his family down
tell
this one is what i dedicated to sherry
what i wanted to start with when we talk
about your story is those beautiful
pictures that we all saw
of you arriving home and being reunited
with your family with sherry and your
two children
how did that moment feel for you
stepping off that plane
back onto british soil and then seeing
your family again
when i think about it now i still form
it difficult to grasp all of that
because
there are many times that i dreamt about
sherry about my kids
and i used to wake up to the ceiling of
my
coffin we used to call because the
ceiling was about about half a meter
above our heads
so
even waking up uh to a ceiling which was
about a few meters away
away from you
it was unbelievable and there were times
that i used to dream and you used to
wake up to that
and it is such an anti-climax then you
wake up to your cell
sometimes in my dreams i used to test
myself
i used to pinch myself
to feel the pain so that to me to make
sure that this is not a dream so you so
it it's still hard to
finally realize that this is now your
reality
i was touching sherry's hands
touching to make sure that yes this is
this is
reality this is happening we became
serious when she was 17. yeah we are
boyfriends and girlfriends and we are
still boyfriends and girlfriends so
that's a long time without
i mean disregarding whatever we have
written and signed we are that's 50
years she is my best friend
in life when did you actually believe
that you were coming home what was the
moment that you thought this is actually
happening i'm going home
it was touch and go up until the last
moment
why was that
because the iranian authorities
were
reluctant
although they had they
had told me that i was going to to be
released but you cannot exactly be sure
and
i'm really grateful to stephanie alcac
she did a great job
uh appointed the last moment she made
sure that uh we were she was
accompanying us to the aircraft
uh and when we took off i mean
she did her job fantastic so so do you
mean you didn't even when you were at
the airport
you were thinking it was only when the
what the wheels
went up yes and you were in the air that
you thought this is even then i was
looking through the window to see if we
are being accompanied by any other
aircraft
and when we actually
left the iranian airspace
then i was sure that
there was no point of return
going back to august the 13th 2017
when you were
arrested tell tell me about
why you were in iran what you were doing
that day and then what happened
well my mom lives in iran and she's
nearly 90 years old
and she had knee problems and
we arranged and we had a surgery for a
knee replacement so one day when i was
going to the local market to have my
suitcase
repaired this zip
didn't didn't walk properly
as i went down the road
in our street
suddenly a car pulled over
and four men i think it was four
they jumped out and said are you mr
shuri and i said yes
and said one of them took the
suitcase from me and the other one said
can please sit in the back
and
i sat in the back seat
two sat on my sides and the two others
uh sat in the front and uh
they started driving and i was wondering
am i being kidnapped or what is it about
so you uh
so as we got into the motorway uh one of
them gave me a piece of paper showed it
to me said read it and it was written on
something like anti-espionage
right
[Music]
decreed that it was a court order
that i should be arrested
and be taken to
a
detention center
then
they they they told me to put on a
blindfold
on my my on my eyes and then i had to
they told me to
lie on put my head on the laps of the
person who was
sitting next to me
so that i could hear
the traffic and i could hear i feel the
bumps and everything but you cannot you
you become
disoriented when you're lying uh on your
side on somebody's lap we mentioned this
into this house i could from
the bottom of my blindfold i could see
very nice carpets
and they took me into a room and i sat
there and my interrogator came and he
used to yeah
and
it started from there and when i was
taken to 209 i was taken to a room to a
cell
and i was left there the cell had
lights strong lights that never went off
there was the sound of this
almost malfunctioning air conditioning
system that
was
continuously going
like that
and
i think a couple of days i was there
without anybody seeing me and i didn't
know what is going on
until my first interrogation i mean were
you thinking this is a misunderstanding
i haven't done anything they don't
believe you
and i didn't know then
the reason why i was there only
long after that we realized when i was
in prison
then when i realized that this is this
relates to a debt
that
britain had to pay to iran
you couldn't speak to anyone nobody came
away they were just
giving the food through these little
holes
and nobody was talking to me
when you say
that they interrogated you what would
what did they do they they sat you in a
room and insisted that you wrote the
thrones down of things you would not
elaborate on that okay now okay uh we
shall leave that for later sure
and okay let's talk about evan prison
you wrote something in the guardian that
i read
very carefully
um
you you
it's a prison that housed intellectuals
and political prisoners
and you said in this article i live in
heaven prison
tehran in the valley of hell
is that was is that how it was was it
was it
as if you were living in house really
that was the value of hell
and because you apart in addition to
your own suffering
you see the suffering of all the people
who are around you
each of them in their in their own
different way
marriages are breaking up
families are disintegrating
and
i was reasoning with myself that
if i when i know that i'm innocent and
i'm here
so everybody else can be innocent
and be there
that must be very hard
to live with knowing that the injustice
the injustice of
being imprisoned
for no reason
was that hard to was that hard to live
with
especially because
if you look at the 68 years of my life
you will not see a single
sign that i was i was having any
political
uh leniencies towards any faction i mean
i was mainly into cosmology i was in
mainly into engineering uh physics
things that i loved and the innovation
that i made in iran uh was a certain
type of concrete form work
that i managed to get a gold award for
that the account i read was actually
really hard to read i think it must have
been unimaginable to live it um
you wrote about
food so foul that only the most needy
prisoners would eat it you talked about
the unbearable stench
from the open sewers you talked about
the windowless room the bed marks the
cockroaches yes the rats the feces
floating
along this open sewage what was the
worst thing or is that just
impossible to say because it was all
just so awful they were saying these are
these are the physical things that you
you see
[Music]
but the suffering of the people
who are
there uh a few of them ended up in
mental hospital i mean these are the
the more pronounced
effects
you said um again your testimony about
fellow prisoners you said that you could
name at least half a dozen who'd
attempted suicide at least two who'd
succeeded
have their names with me but i cannot
reveal them but yeah you said there were
a dozen taken to a mental hospital
some had suffered permanent damage due
to electrical shock treatment
you said two dozen had developed severe
post arrest medical conditions and you
said at least two captives
were killed on their interrogations
or
to have been to have said that they were
there they committed suicide one of them
was kavu zamami
uh the environmentalists
i mean
uh
such fine people such nice people
moratabas
oh i mean i he should be here with us he
he needs medical attention
and he's not getting it
i mean we cannot celebrate anything
without them being here
i am feeling so much so bitter
that
he was not on the same plane
with us
and i'm not going to be quiet until he
is back and until the rest of the
duo nationals are released
i feel that i have left
such fine people
you've written about you did attempt yes
that was when i was in the interrogation
center
and
i made a few attempts
one of them the scars are on my wrist
when i wanted to cut my wrist
these are the well after four years they
are
improving a little bit but uh
and they barged in and they they
undressed me and they took everything
away
uh that did that wasn't successful so i
remembered the books that i used to see
for example the people who were starving
in auschwitz
so i thought perhaps if i make a passive
uh hungry strike because you usually may
you do a hunger strike to protest
against something
because of the threats which i'm not
going to delve into
so i decided not to be
and
i remember they were giving eggs boiled
eggs for that for breakfast that morning
and i stopped
eating
for four days i did not even drink water
then i thought perhaps my blood would
thicken and if i have a stroke then
i'll be handed over to drink water
i didn't want to be so i didn't want to
drink water i didn't want to drink any
to eat anything you lost 17 kilograms in
17 days yes and
that is when my interrogator called me
and he said we are going to show some
kindness and we are going to send you
to a suite and that suite is a cell of
the same size but with three other
people in it
i cried and i insisted because i was
going to i was telling myself that
within the next month
job is accomplished my mission is
accomplished
uh
and i started crying and insisting that
i don't want to be with people i want to
be in the cell of course they had
discovered that i had i was not eating
so they moved me to that cell and the
people in that cell they didn't succeed
in persuading me to eat that evening but
from the next day
i stopped my hungry strike there were
some moments
of
hope
companionship
resilience that you've shown in
spades but you wrote powerfully about
the university of evan
and prisoners given given each other's
lessons
i mean was that something that that
sustained you that helped you this
what tell us about the the university
well you could see uh talented people
around you
this person is
a specialist he has got a phd in quantum
physics the other one has got a phd was
a university professor
up until the moment of his arrest he was
busy lecturing at the university
teaching economics
or
similar cases like that so you would
actually get to know these people
and you would offer
if they could
teach you
a little bit of that
and
to escape from loneliness they would
also welcome that
so once i decided
that we should form a group
and that started with their poetry group
okay
and we were about eight or nine we used
to sit together
and they used to how we had this
satirist
writer i cannot name him
and he started teaching us how to write
short stories
and some of them were my role models i
had a friend who had an execution center
sentence over his head
and i was learning a lot from him
somehow we we try to
treat each other
there isn't any other choice
what did you learn from him
resilience
resistance
because every morning when he
woke up say at the middle of the night
he could be called for to be taken to
the gallows
i mean how can you live a life like that
we had we had a few what executions
sentences
and you don't know what's going to
happen to them now no will you be able
to keep in touch is it very very
difficult
very difficult that must be hard yes
i think the best thing for us is that
we should concentrate
not on us because we are now safe we are
here
we should concentrate on the people we
have left behind
be it your nationals or mono nationals
and
a lot of effort is needed
that things like this won't happen
many of them are innocent
and their lives are being destroyed
just finally you about have imprisoned
you wrote this i have to stop feeling
stop the feeling of pure rage or
self-pity breakers into choice only
survival i'm not the same person who
stepped into the prison
so
i mean this is a
maybe a hard question to answer but how
do you feel now do you feel joyous
do you feel furious are you relieved are
you all of those things a mixture of
it's a mixture of all of that yeah i
cannot
be joyful
because i've got friends back there
who are going through the same suffering
how can i celebrate how can i be be
happy
it's
momentary for example you see
perhaps you see a clip that my son
bought
fish and chips for me for example and
it was so nice
eating fish and chips after nearly five
years or having my first beer
these are
little moments which are quite quite
nice they are quite important but
when you think holistically on the on
the on the matter you you cannot be
feeling happy
but do you feel guilty i mean you can't
feel guilty that you've been released it
wasn't your fault that you were
imprisoned
you always tell yourself is it
that thing that i could do or the other
thing that would make the change
so that
another person would be
accompanying me in that aeroplane
again i stress on the fact that murat is
one of them
[Music]
but there are many others
but i'm not at liberty to to name them
they're there
the feeling
the the suffering is even more
intensified when you are left behind
we have had people we went to their
send-offs at the foot of the staircase
we used to clap for them we used to
share and and as they were leaving we
could feel the positive atmosphere that
we have someone who is being released
from this cage
and we would
congratulate each other as well and
hoping and wishing that i hope your you
will be the next one and the other ones
would say you would be that the next one
but in your heart
you were somehow
feeling that when is it going to be my
time
so when i was walking up those uh
those uh stairs waving at everybody to
say goodbye
i could see that i'm yeah you you feel
that you're betraying them you feel that
you don't deserve this
it is them
because they have been so good to you
but you do deserve it
everybody deserves it
and i'm not going to be quiet until i
see all of them back home
and the mono nationals were there to be
to be released
or to be retried at least
by a fair judge
let's go on to you coming home and the
deal that the government struck
um
nazzanin who you flew home with um
said yesterday
that she should have been freed six
years ago it shouldn't have taken five
foreign secretaries to secure her
release
you were held captive for nearly five
years
under four different foreign
secretaries
did you feel
forgotten
i agree with nazanin 100
she in fact put her finger on the right
button and by saying that
she should have been here years ago
if that debt was paid that wasn't a
ransom that was a debt
that the british government owed
should have been paid and if it was paid
perhaps none of this would have happened
so uh
yeah i feel a bit angry
sherry cherry tried to get
[Music]
an audience with
the prime minister with with boris
johnson to talk about your case
her letters were never answered
it took
even a punishment because i had i
received my second indictment
because partly because of the voice
message i sent to boris johnson
so i risked my safety
but i managed to
convey that message
to him
unfortunately he did not spend even five
minutes to give a telephone call to my
family
to say that you are there
i see you
tell us about the voicemail
thing that i was angry because
uh
i at the same time i was blaming
uh
those who captured us
uh i was blaming the british government
why don't you do anything about this do
we need a death a dead person in our
hands so that you would start
shaking and moving
and doing something about it
and
i was really angry
and that's why i decided to
send that voice message
hoping that there it would make a change
and this was in what 2019 yes i think so
yeah
and um
and sherry did not get a response at all
and subsequently and it took it took
richard a hunger strike yes
so you sent boris johnson a voice note
in 2020
to try and get your case
heard by the pm did sherry hear back
from him
nope
unfortunately she made many attempts
and it was all of them were unsuccessful
and since you've come home
the prime minister's written to you and
sharing would like to see last night we
received a letter
now he is eager to see us
how'd you find how would you interpret
that
well how do you feel about that
i think that
it's a bit of oppressionism involved in
it at the same time as
all of this has happened uh under his
command
so one could argue that it was the
british government the prison british
government which succeeded in doing that
which is correct at the same time
we could say that why didn't you contact
us my family
and now you are eager
to do that
how would you expect us
to absorb that how would you expect us
to think about our view
with this letter now
what couldn't this letter be sent
five months ago
a year ago
two years ago
why now
and will you will you see him or you're
not deciding i'm not sure okay
just to go back to you and sherry you
studied in the uk
before returning
to iran and you raised your children in
iran but you came back to the uk 17
years ago and you spent so much of your
life here
do you think part of
some of the difficulties with your case
as well was because there was a feeling
that
because you didn't spend your entire
life in the uk that you weren't properly
british was that something that was
underlying this and that must aggrieve
you if it was surely this is one of the
criticisms that i have to make is that
when they were
uh going to uh my lawyers were applying
for uh diplomatic protection which
nazine got right yes
uh
our britishness
came on the question okay
how british are you
how british should i be
this is the place that we love to be
this is the place we return to
this is the place that we raised our
kids and now both of them have been
educated
your university educated people who are
actually serving in this country
how british can should you be
and yet we were not recognized as that
at least practically we were not
make you feel quite angry yes
and particularly for sherry because she
was
here trying to get you that that formal
diplomatic protection that diplomatic
protection status it elevates the case
to becoming a formal state-state issue
so it can make a real difference can't
it yes
which we
did not benefit from it
could you go back to iran
i dare not
that's don't want to go through through
the same
ordeal
that's the loss too though isn't it
because your parents
yes my mom is there and i'm worried
about her yeah
i'm sorry for that that's
um extremely worried about her
there was a fundraiser to pay your fine
for your release what happened to that
money and how much did you raise and
what are you going to do with it
first of all i have to
express my gratitude to the british
public
who was so supportive
sherry
had to raise that money overnight
they took everybody the family members
their credit cards whatever they had to
actually to come with that sum
how much did you have to pay
nearly 20
that was 33 000 euros and the government
didn't pay that money for you
and
then they started doing this fundraising
and i'm really grateful
now we have exceeded that
amount and what we intend to do is
to use parts of it for the family to
come
to get on his feet and the rest we are
going to put it in good use uh perhaps
amnesty international is going to be a
good candidate that's great well it must
have been hard for sure when you were
keeping the house
go in and there are many deaths yeah
sure ellicott uh sacrificed a good
portion of her business yeah uh
campaigning for him
ariane
behind the scene but he was actually
doing the same
okay well look let's talk to let's talk
about your last week i'm coming home
now you've told me about the um
champagne on the plane i heard that you
had a beer in the garden as well
do you have a beer
um what was the first thing you chose to
eat
it was english breakfast british
breakfast
again bacon bacon i love very much and
and sherry has become
not a vegetarian but she doesn't take so
she she was sitting next to me
and i could see that she was taking all
the bits of bacon in her plate and was
transferring it to my place so extra
portions for you well there you go um
and what did you do what did you all do
at the weekend because you had your
children with you and yes yes and in the
safe house that we were we were looked
after yeah first class was that lovely
it was amazing yes and the dogs were
there and romeo recognized me
i'm going to ask you one more thing it's
your birthday next month
8th of april yeah how are you going to
celebrate
i'll leave it to sherry and
and the kids
again
it is not going to be a full celebration
unfortunately until they said the main
celebration is when maura tarbus
returns together with the rest of the
duo nationals
then we are going to raise our
glasses of champagne all together that
will be that will be my birthday that
will be my no rules
that will be the day
that i imagine should happen and
i i expect for it to happen anymore okay
alicia thank you so much let's talk to
you it's an absolute pleasure same here
thank you
anushay ashori there well in response to
the interview a government spokesperson
said from the prime minister down this
government has been committed to
securing the release of a new shay
ashori it was always entirely in iran's
gift to do this but uk ministers and
diplomats were tireless in working to
secure his freedom and are delighted
he's now home
stay with us coming up next the
chancellor of the exchequer rishi sunac
[Music]
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over to phillip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of america's opioid
crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
christchurch has been changed forever by
what happened
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
welcome back yesterday the chancellor
rishi sunak gave his so-called spring
statement looking ahead to turbulent
economic times if he thought it would
reassure people he was mistaken the
revelations about the soaring cost of
living and the plummeting drop in
disposable income have been startling it
wasn't meant to be like this the chance
was widely spoken off as a confident and
charismatic politician sometimes even as
a prime minister in waiting now he finds
himself presiding over problems
affecting millions of people's jobs and
families does he acknowledge the scale
of the pain and can he really empathize
with it
rishi sonnet thank you very much for
being on the show and talking to me the
day after your spring statement look the
big headline of it obviously was that
living standards are going to fall to
their lowest level in over
six decades let's just take that in
since the 1950s but millions of people
will have been watching your statement
they're reading the headlines and
they're very stressed and they're very
anxious are you
yeah i'm i'm anxious on their behalf and
i know that it's the number one concern
that people have right now families are
struggling with the rising cost of lots
of things and that's why in the spring
statement
i wanted to make sure that we
demonstrated we're on people's side and
we
announced the tax plan that will deliver
the biggest net cut taxes net cut to
personal taxes in two years well well in
quarter of a century taken together but
i guess taking a step back i've always
tried to be honest with people i can't
you know i can't protect them from
absolutely everything that we face but
where we can make a difference we will
and i'm confident that the plan
yesterday will be but you you actually
during covert judged the public mood
very well and you did come in behind
people
you're not really doing that now really
i mean
what you've just talked to me about
is in this unprecedented moment of
inflation at a four decade high uh
living standards fall into the lowest
levels in this year since the 1950s it
is unprecedented and you haven't really
been able to respond
uh in a way that perhaps people need
is that because you just simply cannot
do that or do you acknowledge that you
might have misjudged the moment that
people feel abandoned well i think
i think the right thing to remember is
the context and they're very different
situations and what we're grappling with
over the last couple years was a
pandemic where the government forcibly
shut down the country and the economy
that's different to dealing with global
inflationary forces which we're not
alone in facing you know the us actually
seeing higher inflation than we are
right now europe similar and the
response to to different economic
situations is necessarily different and
and actually i think what we've done is
substantial if you take together you
know nine billion pounds to help people
with energy bills announced last month
the significant tax cuts that we
announced yesterday they will all help
but of course they can't mitigate
all the difficulties that high inflation
is is causing no chancellor could do
that it's like bringing a pea shooter to
a gunfight isn't it i mean the level of
support is only scratching the surface
of the actual reality of people's lives
you do acknowledge that i you can make
an argument about you're limited in what
you can do but at least acknowledge that
the pain people are going to feel is
real and that as a government you cannot
really
offset it oh gosh i've been completely
honest about that and i've always said
that you know no government can fully
offset the impact of inflation running
at those levels that's the same here as
it is in any other country you're
absolutely right and i haven't shied
away from being honest with people about
that you know we it is impossible to
fully protect people against some of
these things and of course our actions
to sanction putin as i said yesterday
and as of others they're not cost free
for us here at home i'm going to bring
you to two specifics which i wanted to
ask you about one was on energy bills it
seems to me that you are going to have
to put in additional support in the
coming months do you accept that that is
likely
so we don't know what's going to happen
in october it's really too early to know
what will happen then and
the energy prices are moving around so
wildly that i don't want people to sit
here right now and think gosh it's going
up by this much or we're not going up we
don't know uh the forecast move around
by the day
you held you held money back you held
money that you could use back it seemed
to me yesterday in order to give you a
cushion to make more interventions is
that fair well i think in general i've
always been responsive to the situation
and it will continue to be responsive to
the situation do you acknowledge about
the absolute positive figures and
doesn't that bother you the idea that
under your leadership
half a million children are going to go
into absolute poverty it's the biggest
figure according to the resolution
foundation outside a recession
well i i mean what we do know is a track
record because there's lots of
projections and speculation about the
future but the track record shows that
over the last 10 years since we've had
conservative governments in charge the
number of people living in poverty has
actually declined by about 1.3 million
people that includes 300 000 children uh
from memory so actually that's a record
that i'm proud of and obviously a lot of
that happened before um you know i was
uh i was imposed but the actions i've
taken over the past couple of years have
ensured that we have protected those on
the lowest incomes the most i understand
you can say about the problems of the
economy and inflation of things out of
your control about global inflation but
to kind of deny the fact that
think tanks that look at this stuff warn
about
inflationary pressure putting people
into poverty uh and and sort of
challenging that i find it's like being
a bit gaslighted to be honest
i'm not denying for one second that
inflation is difficult of course it's
difficult and it's most difficult for
those online my point is you could have
given more support to low incomes and
you chose to target tax and that's your
decision as chancellor but just
acknowledge that you chose to target
your tax cuts in a different way i
actually chose to target them
specifically in a way that is beneficial
for those on low and middle incomes and
actually you quoted lots of think tanks
they also said that the best way to help
those on low incomes through the tax
system is to raise national insurance
thresholds it is the policy that
delivers the most benefit
well rishi's son out there on the spring
statement but stay with us because we're
going to have more from him
coming up next
i'm going to talk to the chancellor
about juggling the pressures of running
the economy and being a dad
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i do want to ask you a little bit
about you and your values and picking up
on your values
your parents
emigrated here in the 1960s from east
africa your father a gp your mother a
pharmacist they opened a chemist and
then they sent you
to one of the best public boarding
schools in the country to winchester and
now you are the chancellor
they were very ambitious for you clearly
you know i'm sitting here talking to you
the product of
lots of people's sacrifice hard work and
kindness and start my grandparents
actually who emigrated together with my
my parents and and you're actually right
about my parents for them education is
everything they thought that was the
best way they could help provide a
better life for me and my younger
brother and sister so for them that was
the focus of their hard work uh was to
provide that opportunity for us and
that's ultimately what motivates me
today it's why i'm in politics it's why
i do this job it's to try and spread
the say you know as much of the
opportunities that i was really
fortunate to enjoy to as many people as
possible and education for me is is one
of the best ways we can do that as a as
a country i wonder what it must have
been like for you going from a
from the background you had into the
upper middle classes
of of british society go into this
public school this one of the best in
the country where you met so many people
from the upper echelons of society what
was that comfortable or was it tough for
yours it's something in between
you know it was an amazing opportunity
er is what it was did you feel like you
were out of place no i mean i you know i
i was really lucky to have that
opportunity it was it was something that
was really extraordinary it certainly
put my life on a different trajectory as
i said it's you know part of the reason
i'm sitting here and i'm really grateful
to have had that opportunity and you
know i look back on that time it's
helped make me who i am as a person and
i'm sure it helps me do the job in the
way that i do it i also have asked
because i just wondered did you fee did
you feel out of place did it feel like a
world you didn't belong in or did you
just adapt
well i probably probably just adapted
because i'm i'm sitting here talking to
you so yeah you probably did okay it's
you know but i i think you know i think
we have an amazing country that is
brilliant at
integrating people from lots of
different backgrounds
into society and that's that's a very
special thing about our country it's
always been an open tolerant welcoming
country and i think if people are if
people are prepared to work hard and
integrate then they're always been
warmly accepted and that's that's what
i've always felt but you did have talked
about racism
and feeling very stung by that so it
wasn't always an opening and there were
points in your life oh gosh of course of
course there were yes and of course i
experienced that growing up and i think
actually
you know now that when i think about
what's happened to the country i think i
said at the same time i think some of
the things that i experienced as a kid
growing up probably you you would much
more
unlikely to see now and that's a sign of
the progress that we that we've made as
a country with your goals do you worry
about it for them about them experience
racism will you think the country no way
if i don't actually right in a way that
i bet my parents probably did worry
about it a bit um not that i've talked
to them explicitly about it i i don't
worry about it for my girls and that
probably tells you a sign of that that's
okay that's a problem that we've made
and we have always been uh there's
always improvement of course there's
always room for improvement it'd be
wrong to pretend that there isn't uh but
i i generally feel really proud of the
way that our country does this i think
it does it i think it does it better
than most and i've got two more things
to ask you just on your your background
so you were very successful you are very
successful you went to oxford then you
went into the city you worked in finance
and a hedge fund you yourself became you
were a self-made millionaire you became
a millionaire you then married a
multi-millionaire one of the wealthiest
women in britain
whose father's a billionaire
you kind of it struck me that you went
from being sort of part of the upper
middle classes of britain to almost
being part of a global elite how did
that affect your outlook on life
well i think actually the the experience
i've had of living and working abroad
and particularly
i spent i studied in california in
silicon valley you still have a home
there don't you yeah then i still and
i've worked there for many years and as
my kids were born there um yeah that's
actually been really helpful because i
think one thing that policymakers and
people in my job need to do is is to
have a global outlook you know that we
need to make sure that britain can
compete
how do you keep it real
yeah you're really wealthy man how do
you keep it real do you take a bus do
you go to the supermarket of course i go
to the supermarket and i you know
whether it's there's lots in north
allerton where we live in in north
yorkshire and t-side is on my you know
my back door so if i step forward like
if my kids are at the cinema at the
weekend we're in darlington we're in
stockton we're at the you know we're at
the clip and climb there those are the
kind of things that i'm doing on the
rare chances i have some time off with
my uh with my kids and you can see that
in the policies we've put in place
because of my constituents because of
that perspective like like all mps i'm
not alone in that it's a wonderful thing
about our system
is that being good constituency mps
means that we are very responsive to
what's going on on the ground in a way
that by the way most other finance
ministers around the world don't have
that in a way that i'm even asking you
this question that because you're
wealthy somehow you might not be in
touch do you find that does that great
with you a bit i know it's entirely
expected in uh in this job so it's
perfectly reasonable question for people
to ask
i just one more thing you've gone from
head boy you're a head boy weren't you
to hedge fund
to chancellor you're pretty successful
you've always been at the top of your
game it seems to me and it always looks
quite effortless as well although i'm
sure it's not
um
what's the one thing that you've got
really badly wrong in your life oh gosh
i think we've only got about 10 seconds
left haven't we so there's a long long
list of things but no i mean look the
thing that is hardest for me is
balancing like everyone is like juggling
your
profession in your personal life it's
juggling your career and your family and
it's trying to be
you know i want to be the best possible
person i can in this job because a lot
of people are counting on me to do a
really good job and like that's a big
responsibility there's a lot of
challenges and at the same time i'm
still a dad and i'm still a husband and
being
good in those roles is also really
important to me and you know candidly
it's a constant struggle what's your
biggest setback though what's the have
you ever had a setback i've had i've had
i've had plenty everyone everyone has
had plenty on a daily basis i'm
confronted with the fact that i can't
ever in this job do all the things that
people would like me to do and i have to
deal with that every single day i have
to every single day know that god i
can't solve all the problems that people
want me to no matter how many hours and
i'm prepared to put in quite a lot and
no matter how many i put in right i
can't solve all those problems i can't
protect everybody against everything
that is coming their way and of course i
have to go to bed every night knowing
that and during the crisis i was worried
that we'd have millions and millions of
people without a job and because of the
actions that we took that thankfully
didn't happen but you know things like
that happen all the time that's what i'm
grappling with day in day out stressful
job yeah once when boris johnson
was asked about his leadership ambitions
he said if the ball came loose from the
back of the scrum which it won't of
course it would be a great great thing
to have a cracker tip is that your
position too well actually pm is more
rugby fan i'm much more crooked than
football fans so i you know i don't know
what the appropriate analogy is but look
as we talked about
at the moment there's a lot going on
there's a big job to do and i'm fully
focused on doing that job and trying to
do it as well as i can but if that
cricket ball came at you would you catch
it at this point i'm just trying to you
know stay at the crease and keep them
keep keep in place and i'll get out if
the football was at your foot would you
try and score a goal i don't know these
are now we're stretching these analogies
i know no i mean again i said i've
actually managed to do more qriket nets
than i've played football in the last
year so it's my one bit of relaxation
now than going through the old cricket
net okay wish you so nice thank you very
very nice thanks for having me thank you
thank you
well that's all for tonight's show thank
you so much for watching and thank you
two to our guest rashi sunak and ashori
coming up next on sky news
western leaders meet at the nato summit
to discuss ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
you